ONLINE ON MAY 22nd.
>>> GOING TO SPACE IS THE
ULTIMATE SOCIAL DISTANCES.
>> CHINA’S RESPONSE TO THE
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK UNDER FIRE
AS SOME STATES LOOK TO HOLD THE
COMMUNIST COUNTRY RIGHTFULLY
ACCOUNTABLE.
MISSISSIPPI NOW THE LATEST TO
SUE THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT,
BLAMING WHAT THEY CALL, QUOTE, A
COVERUP FOR THE SUFFERING OF
MORE THAN 5,000 RESIDENTS
AFFECTED WITH THE RYE JUST VIRUS
STATE, NOT TO MENTION THE
BUSINESSES IMPACTED.
MISSISSIPPI’S ATTORNEY GENERAL
LYNN FITCH JOINS US NOW.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
TELL US ABOUT THE SUIT YOU ARE
BRINGING ON BEHALF OF
MISSISSIPPI AGAINST THE
COMMUNIST CHINESE.
>> GOOD MORNING.
IT’S A PLEASURE TO BE WITH Y’ALL
THIS MORNING.
MY ROLE AS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
IS TO PROTECT ALL MISS
MISSISSIPPIANS.
THIS SUIT ALLOWS US TO SEEK
JUSTICE AND HOLD CHINA
ACCOUNTABLE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THEY’VE
DONE, IT’S A MALICIOUS AND
DANGEROUS COVERUP.
THE CORONAVIRUS HAS KILLED.
THE CORONAVIRUS HAS CAUSED
SERIOUS MEDICAL DAMAGE AND HARM
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY, OUR STATE,
IT’S DESTROYED OUR BUSINESSES
AND IT’S ALTERED THE WAY
AMERICANS WILL LIVE.
SO WE HAVE TO REBUILD.
AND SO WE SEE THE DAMAGE, THE
ISSUES THEY HAVE CAUSED, SO I’M
BRINGING THE SUIT ON BEHALF OF
MISSISSIPPIANS.
>> WHAT ARE THE PROSPECTS OF
THIS LAWSUIT AGAINST ONE OF THE
LARGEST COUNTRIES ON THE PLANET
WHO IS GOING TO WANT TO JUST
SWAT IT ASIDE, DOESN’T EVEN TAKE
RESPONSIBLE ON THE INTERNATIONAL
STAGE.
>> THAT’S TRUE.
IIT’S THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
WE MUST HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY’VE GONE IN AND THEY HAVE
SILENCED DOCTORS AND
JOURNALISTS, WHISTLEBLOWERS,
THEY HAVE CAUSED US NOT TO BE
PREPARED AND THIS HAS DAMAGED US
ON SO MANY LEVELS, LOSS OF LIFE,
ECONOMIC DAMAGES, AND SO IT’S A
TOUGH ONE BUT WE’RE GOING TO WIN
BECAUSE WE’RE GOING TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE AND WE MUST DO THAT
IN ORDER TO MAKE THEM NOT GO
DOWN THIS PATH.
THEY CANNOT CONTINUE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF AMERICA.
>> AMEN.
WELL SAID.
GOOD LUCK WITH THE SUIT.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU AS THE CHIEF
LAWMAKER IN MISSISSIPPI, BILL
BARR CALLED INTO QUESTION SOME
OF THE STAY AT HOME ORDERS, HOW
FAR SHOULD GOVERNMENT GO.
HOW HAVE YOU VIEWED THE POWERS
IN THE STATE OF MISSISSIPPI AS
FAR AS ALLOWING RESIDENTS TO GET
BACK TO WORK.
>> WE’RE ALWAYS READY TO GET
BACK TO WORK BUT WE’RE GOING TO
DO IT VERY CAREFULLY, VERY
CAUTIOUSLY, FOLLOWING THE
EXECUTIVES ORDERS OF OUR
GOVERNOR.
WE MUST PROTECT ALL MISS
MISSISSIPPIANS BUT DO IT THE
RIGHT WAY TO GET US BACK TO
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY.
>> I HAVE A FEELING IN
MISSISSIPPI THE BILL OF RIGHTS
IS NOT ABOVE YOUR PAY GRADE LIKE
GOVERNOR MURPHY SAID IN NEW
JERSEY.
GOOD STUFF.
ATTORNEY GENERAL, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US THIS
MORNING.
GOOD LUCK WITH THAT SUIT AGAINST
THE COMMUNIST CHINESE.